I think a lot of people feel that a set
decorator is akin to an interior
decorator and that we are mostly
responsible for having taste and doing
the shopping people think it's all
shopping that all you do is go around
and find things and it's just much more
involved than that people think we just
shop and that we are interior designers
we're not interior designers and we're
not set designer doesn't a lot of people
think we are we do the same similar kind
of work as interior decorators that
we're interior decorators
people often say to me that must be so
much fun what how glamorous how
wonderful
I think they view the set decorator is
kind of a glamorous job the biggest
mystery is that people just think it's
moving furniture or making choices and
it is about telling a visual narrative
on every level
the psychology of each of each character
that's written how they live where they
live what they do you have to do
tremendous research to create that
character and it's not always in the
script we bring so many different
talents to the one job classification we
really are historians and
anthropologists sociologists I'm the
sociologist of the picture I have to
really look into the backgrounds of the
characters and the environments
sometimes the environment doesn't even
have a character so it's a big warehouse
that a big action sequence needs to
occur in and then you have to kind of
make up a tarik tur we kind of take the
script and we mine it for details I
think it was Marvin March who said we
have a split second to let everyone know
where we are or what kind of person it
is or what they collect you have to work
with budget you have to work with a lot
of personalities you have to work with a
large team of people that are actually
making the movie from the director to
the cinematographer the producers and
the actors you would hope that
we would add a familiarity that we would
help guide the story and allow the actor
to come in and in and just populate the
space as one would in real life what we
do is to create those spaces in which
they that tell the story a set decorator
is responsible for creating the visual
story and to serve the story of the
character to facilitate enhance and
otherwise bring to fruition the the
vision set forth by the production
designer and the director for the film
the concept comes from you know
collaboration with the director and the
designer what what we think we want it
to look like a set wants to look like or
what it's trying to say and then I think
you know then the the designer draws up
the walls and the concepts and things
like that and then the set is made the
walls the floors ceilings and then
basically I have to put everything into
it to make it a set and you'd better do
your research because someone somewhere
in Des Moines Iowa is going to call you
a year later and say where did you get
that thing that was wrong or I want that
you